welcome to this video playing shushing
hi double 08 ok let's continue this
match against the sky cream game 20 yeah
we already have a couple yeah I think
you also did something here I'm on minus
one check ok yeah typical Queens Indian
don't know how to play you actually take
the tick on c5 on 93 let's III shouldn't
be that bad ok we have those trades now
but ok it's probably not very um
ambitious but should be ok in the sense
of being about equal Queen f3 there for
the pin hmm I can check g five push-ups
III rooks you one but then queen bee 7
this is some somehow a problem I don't
think so texting is 95 them mmm 10 ok
let's go cleaner 32 bit unnatural this
whole thing with my in the unstable
night damn i was out for 95 m
and not not good not good at all
it's quite a quite an uncomfortable
position in 95 them
Jim don't have don't have a good move
here this is this is not even the best I
think but ok thought 95 is much more of
a problem okay knight c6 here maybe you
cannot take on c1 anyway and so I don't
see it don't see the point 97 is there
before where do you go
so one can take a eight but I can all
that can also take c5 now maybe start
with that they probably both win Leigh
was just too confident down after I'd
miss played the opening okay I can check
and check here and take a tour take heed
first let's take that first um so rookie
one I guess so what is this actually has
33 pounds for a rookie right here three
points for Oakland check
so where is he going like you for
something let's get the night back here
into the game don't want it under check
all the time so where to go f5 probably
night to d5 would be nice get something
straight it and rope deform and eric d 8
is also good if i can manage that his
background is quite quite weak so would
be nice to do 95 here right get rid of
that when I look on d1 hangs my hook on
the wall Hanks just great just great iam
can i'm ok i have it no I don't have
that wait
it's all all hard to believe ok I can
take here Queen h5 is a nice louth Queen
h7 is a nice little trick can be
overlooked easily Anastasia's made time
morning he didn't overlook it so let's
take him the Knight to f5 that is my
idea
yeah it's not easy already time boys
yeah I really what I'm doing against
this player is quite unspeakable playing
really bad chest I once had a game where
where I was a compile was a piece up for
nothing and I still managed to lose and
this was so almost the same thing is
Miss played it again check but twenty
senses not much check
might be doable yeah it is doable okay
it made
he writes to me so lucky I'm sorry but
you play total nonsense at the
beginnings of the games giving me a
rookie and stuff I played badly I know
but this doesn't have to be this is not
so lucky you blundered the whole board
there buddy don't get it really
sometimes I can take the three year or
whatever I mean this is just a plus five
position which I play terribly yes but
this doesn't mean it was lucky and I can
take it you take age seven here I saw
them made yeah but just I just saw it
from d5 don't ask me why I didn't saw it
from age 5 funny yeah okay and I g6 now
is also Winningham I'm technically
sometimes completely blind yeah check
this is just just winning very quickly
yeah now he misplayed that end game
again which is just a drawing course
yeah and he had starts to check its lost
again I think don't think how he keeps
his pawn their check check check but I
really don't see how this is so lucky I
mean he was down a million yeah during
this game okay we both made mistakes but
it doesn't it's not not about luck it
just about me being totally incompetent
sometimes from with the tactics if I
would be technically a better i would
probably have a huge score against the
sky which i haven't it's just fifty
percent okay well thanks for watching